Oh
when next speaker is Trent McConaughey
and he has multi-dimensional skill set
is also the founder and CEO of solid or
design automation so he's going to talk
today about driving Moore's law with
Python powered machine learning thank
you hello everyone thanks for the
introduction
it's really a pleasure to be here
normally I present machine learning
conferences and circuit design
conferences so it's really cool to be at
a conference on Python myself I've been
using Python since about 2001 and
industrially since about 2002 so many
years of Python it's pretty cool to
actually be in a conference surrounded
by Python users I'll get started
very simple outline I'm gonna talk about
Moore's law and then I'm going to talk
about how Python and machine learning
help so there's actually a lot of
Moore's laws out there or things sort of
like Moore's Law so there's the Moore's
law of brain scanning and if you look
you know in 1973 or so there was a
resolution of about three millimeters
but as the years rolled on as the years
passed the resolution went from three
millimeters to one millimeter and it
just keeps going and going and going all
the way to in about three or 2,000
resolution of 0.1 millimeters now the
cool thing on this chart is the y-axis
it's a log scale right so what that
means is it's an exponential decrease in
the degree of resolution that that
people are getting and that's pretty
cool right with with Exponential's very
interesting things happen if you wait
awhile
there's a Moore's law for internet hosts
going back to 1980 up till now and
Beyond we've had this just explosion in
the number of internet hosts out there
those are Moore's Law for DNA sequencing
so it was kind of plodding along you
know the cost of sequencing one human
genome was pretty expensive back in 1965
or 1970 we couldn't do it it was just
too expensive basically but it kept
producing it kept producing and starting
in about 1995 that exponent changed
actually 1995 2000 and it just got
really crazy went from about 1.5 X a
year to about 10 X here and that's cool
right
um Exponential's can change due to
different things happening
and I'm going to get to the answer of
why this happened in just a couple
slides but once again there's sort of a
Moore's law of DNA sequencing and an
exponential change in performance or
price or something over time so what is
the real Moore's Law anyway right
well the real Moore's Law please stand
up so maybe it's transistors for chip so
we can look here this is according to
Intel processors you know if you have a
micro processor from Intel starting in
1971 the Intel 4004 chip had about 2,000
transistors
right but then as time went on Bible
1980 with the 8086 it was about 20,000
write and keep going keep going keep
going and by book 2006 the the Itanium 2
had on the order of billion processors I
mean sorry on the order of billion
transistors these days were actually at
about 2 billion 5 billion even 10
billion transistors per chip which is
pretty cool but you know what that
actually isn't the real Moore's law
maybe it's calculations per dollar so
maybe we can say hey for $1000 how many
flops can I do well you know that has
gotten a lot better a lot better over
the years - which is pretty cool but
that's not the real Moore's law either
here's the actual Moore's law
it's a bhoot transistor size which also
therefore relates to density and this is
just the last several years and a few
years going to the future of course you
could back translate this all the way
back to the 60s and basically in general
and in transistor you've got a channel
which electrons flow through - think of
it like a pipe and you've got you know
water coming in one side water coming
out the other and the length of that
channel has resistance so if you have a
longer pipe then it takes longer for the
water to get from one end to the other
so over time the length of this pipe has
been shortening shortening shortening
and in fact it's become so useful to
have this Moore's Law happening that
it's become a schedule so this is the
reference here is from the ITRs 2011
international technology roadmap for
semiconductors so the 300 billion dollar
semiconductor industry actually sits
down every year there's about 300 500
people who sit down and actually come up
with a roadmap for the next year for the
next five years and ten
and to try to come up with ways to make
sure that Moore's law doesn't end and to
make sure that this exponential keeps
happening so going back actually Moore's
Law is pretty cool because one of the
phenomenons that happens is when silicon
touches something I like to think of it
like a Midas touch so in the case of DNA
sequencing what happened when the
exponential change from 1.5 X to 10x a
year that's when DNA sequencing started
to be used by machines instead of
scientists in a lab playing with test
tubes manually instead it started going
through these sequencing machines and
this was popularized by the likes of
craig Venter at cellar genomics and so
on and so forth so basically and you see
this over and over happening in all
these different industries and there's a
lot other examples from Y ology
especially that we're seeing in the last
10 years and you might ask well what
about Moore's law itself how does how do
we manage to get these computers to get
smaller and smaller every year about one
point it's about 2x over 18 months well
this is actually the silicon Midas touch
applied to itself okay so that means
that you use the current generation of
machines of CPUs of software etc to help
design the next generation if you think
about it it's sort of like the ultimate
bootstrap and then of course you have
software tools sitting on top to help
drive this and this is computer-aided
design software CAD software Moore's law
is very much a powerful now it's really
a bull because hinted at as hinted by
the the silicon touching everything
writing this bull is what has enabled
all these other advances so starting at
the bottom we have these companies like
in Phi n X psi dents and what they do is
they build chips that go inside servers
and racks of computers in general and
then that computing helps to drive the
cloud and inside the cloud you have
content from the lecture of YouTube and
Hulu and Netflix and all these things
and cloud computing which helps to
enable that so that's that's one example
but there's other companies out there
there's companies like Broadcom Abaco
Huawei and they drive communications
infrastructure and then of course we see
a lot about the consumer side where this
companies like Sony and apple and
Qualcomm and they're built designing a
lot of chips for consumers so your your
iPhone's and your tab
and all the sort of stuff this is driven
by these guys so we hear a lot about
Apple especially they are not only a
computer company they actually design
computer chips so and that's really
important they've understood that it's
really matters for them and Moore's law
has enabled all these amazing things
that we see especially at the level of
content and also at the level of of
consumer devices there's a problem with
Moore's law there's actually always
problems with Moore's law and scientists
try to figure out how to fix this
engineers entrepreneurs and so on the
problem right now is what I like to call
variation gone wild I had a picture for
this but my wife made me take it away so
let's just say variation went wild
here's the problem
transistors are shrinking but atoms
aren't so as we started you know you go
back even 10 years you were to 180
nanometers now we're at about 22
nanometers so it's 22 nanometers going
from this end of the channel to this end
of the channel the electrons flow from
here to here okay so this is 10 years
ago this is now so basically you used to
have avicad row size counts for the
number of atoms inside a transistor you
know 10 to the 23rd but now we've got in
this sort of thing a thousand ten
thousand and what this means then is so
in this channel here when the electrons
flow from here to here this thing on top
this is called the gate and it's only
one or two atoms thick this is the thing
that controls how much electrons flow
through so twisting it up is sort of
like twisting the faucet and you're in
your bathtub as you twist the faucet
more and more and more water comes out
so this thing that's only one or two
atoms thick what that means is imagine
if you want to twist your faucet and it
just suddenly like triples how much how
open your bathtub is that's really a
problem right you don't have very much
control over the amount of water that's
flowing through and that of course can
be very troublesome when you're trying
to design a circuit that has supposed to
be you know one one percent precision
five percent precision 10% even suddenly
you're getting these 2 X's of variation
and that's exactly the challenge that we
see here so if you have this variation
in manufacturing and this is actually
statistical in a real physics sense so
when you're a manufacturing chip there's
these atoms that kind of float down and
they lay themselves on a silicon and
it's very much put down in a random
sense and this is actually one of the
things that enables
large-scale manufacturing it's what
enables having 1 billion or 10 billion
transistors on a chip but the problem is
this sort of process of doping that it's
called because it's random in a very
physical and a true physic sense there's
random doping effects that cause this
variation its variation at the device
level one transistor at a time that
propagates the variation at a circuit
level so with things like amplifiers and
filters and bias generators and that
therefore translates from the device all
the way to the circuit and at the
circuit level as well you might have a
microprocessor if you manufacture 10
microprocessors
one might be 2 gigahertz and the other
one might be 1 gigahertz or even point 1
gigahertz so you have this giant
variation in the performance of these
things and it can also happen in terms
of power consumption so you might buy a
cell phone and your buddy buys a cell
phone and your cell phone dies after 2
hours and your buddy's like hey my cell
phone doesn't die at all all day long
and that actually can happen so this is
really a problem it didn't it wasn't a
problem five years ago or 10 years ago
it is now so this is really a problem
then and we want the problem also is we
want to keep Moore's law going so we
want to cut the size of the transistor
by 2 every 18 months this 300 billion
dollar industry relies on it and all
these advances in computing and and
cloud and so on also rely on it so some
of the some challenges are things like
you've got a memory with 1 billion bits
so you've got your 1 gigabit flash drive
how do you verify that how do you make
sure that every single one of those bits
is sufficiently reliable such that you
can ship it so you can manufacture it so
that you don't lose money how do you
improve that design how do you verify a
PLL with 3,000 corners so the idea here
is a PLL it's just another sort of
circuit just like an amplifier ok and
you have to account for variation and
you have to say it has to work when it's
plus 50 degrees Celsius you have to work
when you're minus 20 degrees Celsius you
have to work if your plot power supply
is 1 point 4 volts or 4 it's 0.8 volts
and all these other conditions to it has
to work when it's in sleep mode and have
to work 102 on mode standby and it used
to be you might have and you have to
look at all the combinations of this ok
so it used to be you might have a couple
powers and a couple temperatures so you
have like four corners total but now
because of all these other challenges in
variation you might have 3000
and the problem is to understand the the
variation in one circuit to simulate
with a circuit it might take 10 minutes
so what used to take 10 minutes times 8
so 80 minutes to verify now it takes 10
minutes times 3000 so it just takes too
long so this is just an example of a
problem and all of this is all about
getting lower power lower delay lower
area higher yield all in less time so
there's a huge number of Engineers out
there in the world who are trying to
actually address this so just like
there's engineers that design cars
mechanical engineers what if a lot of
electrical engineers do they work for
Sony or Apple for example they go in
every day to work they sit down at the
computer they work with CAD tools to
design computer chips okay and they're
having real problem troubles so with
Moore's law including variation how
might you address this and the thing
that my company hit upon back in 2004
run when you're starting to found it was
let's use machine learning to abstract
away the variation from the perspective
of the designer okay
so the designer designers don't know
about machine learning at all they're
they tend to know a lot about analysis
with with equations and Fourier
transforms and a lot of other really
amazing mathematical tools but a machine
learning isn't one among them it
definitely was in among them in 2004 and
these days it's even less so what we
realized is let's let the designer keep
having his own flow the flow that he's
always had and let's just hide all the
the challenges of variation under the
hood so that and we used the tools from
machine learning to do that and by doing
this it helps designers to just keep
going going going and that's basically
what my company does Seletar design we
build machine learning powered CAD tools
to help drive Moore's law we're not the
only company out there building CAD
tools of course there's several
companies in the world that do this but
really our specialty has been using
machine learning and its really been a
core strength other companies are
starting to realize that hey these
cielito guys are onto something and
we've seen a lot of others start to
follow suit
but we've been pioneering this for the
last ten years so let's talk about
machine learning in Moore's law and as I
talked to the beginning I've been using
Python
long time my company as well about 99%
of the codebase of my company is Python
hundreds of thousands of line of Python
we've been shipping it production since
about 2005 so we're also going to talk
about how python is being used to drive
this machine learning to drive Moore's
law and how I'm going to do it is just a
series of examples some of them just a
couple slides some of them five slides
just to get kind of give you guys a
flavor of you know how all this code all
this machine learning code and all these
ideas with Python might translate into
real world use that actually end up
inside the cell phones and everyone's
pocket here
okay so here's one example what on the
Left what we have is a circuit this is
an OTA it's a type of amplifier
basically so in comes one signal and up
comes a signal that's 10x 100x larger
and what you want is you want to say hey
I'm a circuit designer I'm used to
working with these analytical equations
I'm used to sitting down and rearranging
the equations to understand what
variables depend on what in what ways
and traditionally they would just use
manual analysis to do this but the
problem is with variation gone wild
those first order on second-order
equations get horribly inaccurate they
get off by 2x or 5x
but what if you could take silicon
accurate data so data that has been
manufactured information about the
devices and so on and pull that back
into equations that the designers can
look at and analyze and get insight into
okay that's the idea here so how it
works is the following you take the
circuit and you run it through something
called spice and spice is actually a
tool that has been around since the 70s
it came out of Berkeley in fact it was
arguably the first open-source tool of
the world BSD is actually partly based
on on this as well as the the OS that
came out of Berkeley around the same
time and so spice is a tool that takes a
circuit disagree as a description of a
netlist so just like we have HTML and
and XML and all these other protocols to
specify things there's also a protocol
to specify a circuit each line basically
says here's the transistor it's
connecting from node 1 to node 2 to node
3 so you can take these descriptions of
these circuits and you can actually
simulate them and this description of
the circuit in text form can get
converted basically into a set of
nonlinear differential equations and
simply get solved with off-the-shelf
solvers that was pioneered by the people
researching spice in the 70s so so what
you can do is you can say I'm gonna come
up with a hundred or a thousand
different points in the space of this
circuit design so changing this
resistance by you know setting
resistance of 1k vs. 10k and another
resistance and another capacitance so
you have a set of vectors you know a
thousand different vectors each vector
is a different design and and then you
simulate each of those with spice and
what you get out is measures of things
like gain and power consumption and so
then what you do from the outcome of
this you basically have a set of X&Y
just like you would do normally in
regression but instead of just doing
simply regression you do something
called symbolic modeling so think of it
like a white box regression instead of
just fitting out a black box model that
predicts stuff you try to make that
model white box so that you can actually
look at it and as a human interpret it
and that's what's going on here so I'll
get into the how but that's the general
idea and what it can spit out is
equations like this so these are actual
real results here this is an equation
for gain gain is minus ten point three
plus seven e to the minus five divided
by ID one that's drain current of
transistor 1 plus 1 point 8 7 times lon
of the C of this equation here and as
you can see there's a ratio here vs ve x
vs t vs v 1 x vs v 3 and so on and so
forth by the way these equations are all
to be within ten percent accuracy so in
this case the offset voltage it turns
out that it was ten percent accurate
simply by giving a constant and it told
you that right so if you say I want to
have 10 percent accurate solutions for
each of my different performance
measures this is what it would spit out
this is super useful to an analog
designer a circuit designer who really
deals with amplifiers and PLL's and
these sorts of circuits the initial way
that we did this was a technique called
genetic programming so this is something
that goes back to actually it was
invented in the 80s it's sort of in two
or three different places but
popularized in the early 90s out of
Stanford and the idea is that you can
represent a function as a tree so for
example this function here for 0.8 times
X 3 plus square root of x to the four
point eight times x three is on this
side so these are combined via this
operator and then this subtree combines
with the plus with this
on this side and in the end we have this
tree representing this equation okay and
what you can do actually is you can
actually search through that space of
possible trees so normally when you
think about optimization you're
typically searching through a space of
parameters Euclidean space or maybe it's
discrete valued Euclidean but it's not
sort of a more generalized space and you
can search through more generalized
space with things like genetic
programming it doesn't have to be
genetic programming you could use
simulated annealing you could use to
buser CH there's a bunch of other
off-the-shelf techniques as well but
genetic programming was really the one
that really pushed this in pioneer
pioneer day so you searched and how you
search the space with genetic
programming for example is you initially
randomly generate one hundred or a
thousand of these trees or ten thousand
so just randomly generate these trees
and then you say you evaluate them so
you see how much error does each tree
have in predicting the output and you
say okay you know what I'm gonna keep
the best half I'm gonna kill the worst
half and if those best half each of them
is gonna get a child so you create a
child from the parent in one of many
ways I'll give an example in the next
slide and then you say okay now I've got
these new children I evaluate those guys
and I simply iterate iterate iterate and
after about 50 iterations you can
actually get pretty interesting trees
they can be pretty small they can be
pretty descriptive descriptive and
pretty easy to understand here's an
example of an operator where you start
with a parent or in this case two
parents on the top here this parent is
one parent and this is the other parent
it's called crossover you basically can
swap sub-expressions so you're swapping
the x x y in this expression with the x
times x plus y sub expression and you
can simply swap those in a you know in
computer science tree base swapping
sense and then you have two children and
then you can evaluate those children you
can view this actually as interpolation
in tree space that's a cool way to think
about it and this is one example
operator there's actually a whole bunch
of operators you can have I I guess I
already talked about some of the example
models with less than 10% error so
that's an example there but overall in
my problem you know I was really caring
about circuit land here I played a lot I
worked a lot with a lot of other machine
learning technologies over the years you
know going back to the mid-90s a
national defense with things like radial
basis function speed
all this sort of stuff and so I had all
these technologies that I'd worked with
over the years so off the shelf I
compared to them right so I compared the
technology that I had built here which I
call caffeine I do like coffee a lot too
much to things like Gaussian process
models to support vector machines a feed
world neural networks boosted feed for
all neural networks splines quadratics
Linear's constants and in this
particular set of benchmarks this is six
different problems it actually had the
lowest lowest error in predicting unseen
data so I was pretty happy about that it
was not only a white box model it was
actually the lowest error in predicting
and I think part of it is that there was
a bias towards reducing the complexity
simply so that people could understand
what was going on and I think that helps
a lot in general if you have this bias
to reduce complexity for with the
implicit aim to understand it also has
the side benefit of just being really
good at predicting stuff and overall in
Python terms
what's the stack here it's actually a
hundred percent Python using a Python
2.7 actually in that case it was even an
earlier Python probably about Python 2.3
or so numpy and scifi custom machine
learning algorithm that I wrote was
grammar constrained genetic programming
it was multi objective as well and then
I actually designed a grammar for
functions so I came up with basically a
language to describe functions in a way
that they're easy to interpret and it's
sort of the general idea of that grammar
is some of products of some of products
I can give more details about all this
if you guys want later and then a third
party circuit simulator now of course
you can use this off-the-shelf or
anything else - not just circuits
because it simply takes in an XY XY
input/output mapping of data now it
turns out that that technology using
genetic programming didn't scale so well
it was good up to about 20 variables but
and you know at first this was fine for
us for the sort of circuits we were
attacking but then we started having
customers saying hey you know I really
want to see white box models for 100
variables for a thousand for 10,000 and
these days even for a hundred thousand
input variables so I I thought about it
a lot and I've been following you know a
lot of things on machine learning but
there was this whole idea this trend in
machine learning
starting in about 2002 and it's been
going through till today what was
driving it was image search and other
search problems the idea of I like to
call it bhal are big hairy audacious
linear regression okay and what it means
is that normally when you think linear
regression you think least squares and
all these you know old school matrix
approaches to do it like you are
decomposition and whatnot and that has
certain constraints right you you always
if you have a hundred some training samp
if you have a hundred variables and you
need at least 101 training samples but
these new approaches they don't need
that because they use regularization so
that actually soft ins the problem and
they have iterative solvers so you can
actually get away even if you have you
know if you have a hundred input
variables you might only need ten
samples and you can actually get
something that's kind of saying right
because what they try to do implicitly
is minimize the degree that you screw up
your prediction afterwards
mathematically it's actually minimizing
the volume of the confidence ellipsoid
but um that's basically the sort of
technology that I was following and I
realize you can build another technology
around this and it's dead simple you
take can you a number of input variables
whether it's thirteen or more and you
explode that out to a hundred thousand
input variables okay by adding a whole
bunch of basis functions so the basis
functions that I use are things like log
and sine and cosine and and x1 squared
x2 squared 1 over x1 squared all this
and also the interactions of those so x1
times x2 x1 times sine of X 2 and if you
do it right you can keep the
computational complexity down such that
it's linear in the number of samples and
quadratic in the number of input
variables total so that's pretty cool so
it's quadratic in the number of initial
input variables and so so that's the
first step the second step is you apply
these bhal or algorithms big hairy
audacious linear regression algorithms
to solve it and on this an elastic net
formulation which if you guys don't know
it's a really happy marriage between
laughs ooh and Ridge regression last who
is a little too aggressive and pruning
variables Ridge regression is a little
too non aggressive so elastic net is
sort of the happy medium and then when
you're doing this pathways learning the
pathways part it basically is tracking
the the complexity versus training error
over time so it starts off by saying I
have zero
and I'm only using a constant basically
and then I have one variable that kicks
in to reduce my training error by a
little bit and then I have two
coefficients that kick in to reduce my
training error that a little bit more
and you keep going and going and going
until your training error stagnates so
you have this set of a trade-off between
complexity the number of variables that
are nonzero and the training error so
then what you can do is you can take
that set and you can simply filter it on
test error so now you have a trade-off
between complexity versus test error and
from there you can say things like I
just want to have the lowest test error
or you want to have that whole set of
models now overall though there's a cool
result here and that is at the
scalability and the speed goes way up so
that's what it shows here the technology
that I showed you a couple slides ago
was right here this was the caffeine
approach the Genetic Programming
approach so to build the typical model
it would take about ten minutes and it
would get a test error about four
percent okay this is the average across
everything
compare that to a linear model or a
quadratic model which have about a 15%
error and they take basically zero
seconds compared to this the technology
here I call it f of X for fast function
extraction it takes also basically zero
I mean one second to second on this
scale looks like zero and it has
actually a lower error yet compared to
the caffeine so I was pretty happy about
that and we actually use this off the
shelf in several other technologies I'll
show you later we deployed this daily
this probably this algorithm has been
run in a blackbox fashion under the hood
and some of our other technologies it's
probably been around a hundred thousand
times now and out there deployed in
industry just it works you trust it you
can consider it sort of a technology in
that way so the stack below this is it's
using these days Python 2.7 and numpy so
I could learn inside scikit-learn
there's like a whole bunch of different
technologies for doing linear regression
including these bhal R approaches so I'm
using coordinate descent pathways
learning so it's just a particular
formulation and yeah and the elastic net
formulation problem to solve and inside
there it's this f of X tool so f of X
wraps the scikit-learn
to explode the number of basis functions
to do that
dominated filtering etc of course this
is general enough for other domains we
have an extension for classification of
course you can just put a you know a
logistic map on top of this and actually
we've open-sourced this too so if you
want to play with it use it its own
there online at Trent St / f of X and
some of my friends have used this I've
never promoted this really heavily but
feel free and use it yeah go for it
I'm gonna keep going though and I'm
gonna talk about several other
technologies that we've been using to
help drive Moore's law using Python
powered machine learning here's one so
here the challenge here is let's say you
want to just understand the distribution
of power consumption so you manufacture
a thousand chips and you want to know
okay what's the average power
consumption what's the you know for the
top five percent what's what's the 95th
percentile power consumption and so on
and so forth so that's up here imagine
here we've manufactured let's just look
like about a thousand samples and this
would be the identity fit on top of it
now you can also transform this density
fit in here the y-axis is the density
actually but it turns out when you have
a long tail it's kind of hard to look at
because it's hard to distinguish what
the density is here versus the density
here but it really matters actually for
a lot of problems you really want to
know whether you're ninety nine point
five percent versus ninety nine point
six percent so it turns out there's a
visualization to help you see that it's
called NQ so you take you take this
y-axis so every single sample here
well the fit and you just transform it
via an exponential transform which is
actually the Gaussian formula the the
normal formula and you have this value
here so this is normal quantile instead
of probability density so you take the
probability density you convert it to a
CDF first the cumulative density then
you transform it to the via this
exponential and you now have a different
y-axis this is really cool because now I
can mr. inglish this part of the tale
from this part of the tale okay that's
super useful you can distinguish ninety
nine point one percent compared to
ninety nine point two percent and that
really matters when you're comparing
ninety-nine point nine nine percent
versus 99.999% much higher yields if you
will so the challenge is that we had was
if you fit a model on here a density
model you can use something like KT
kernel density estimation right and what
you would do with KDE is you just have a
tiny little Gaussian on top of each of
points okay and it estimates what the
Sigma for that Gaussian is based on the
overall spread number of points that
sort of thing
the challenge is with that the tails
drop off really quickly so if you
convert it to this normal quantile plot
what you would have is you would have
this curve that would look like this
here but then it seems to get here it
would just drop off and go to basically
like essentially zero density and that's
really a problem because that
extrapolates really badly and what we
wanted what our engineers wanted our
users designing computer chips they were
wanting to say hey I've done all these
samples and this gives me tells me about
yield of three Sigma so that's ninety
nine point seven percent yield they want
to know what's going on it's a four
Sigma which is ninety nine point nine
nine percent yield so it's a failure
rate of one in ten thousand versus one
in a thousand or one in ten million okay
and so the KDE something off the shelf
like KT that's nonparametric just simply
failed how we out what we did we simply
built many density models so dead simple
we looked at a whole bunch of fancy
approaches in the end we just build a
Gaussian a mixture of two gaussians a
mixture of three gaussians four
gaussians five and six and so on to
lognormal a uniform o'reilly
distribution KDE is a back up and even a
few more and then we picked the model
with the best fit but it couldn't be
just the best fit according to Emily
Emily is really caring about densities
in this space what we really cared about
was being able to extrapolate in a same
way so basically we did a least squares
fit in NQ space that was our way of
measuring the goodness okay so in the
end a deadly simple algorithm but this
works and scales in a really beautiful
way so engineers like that
what's the stack well Python 2.7 M PI we
use some sci-fi stuff so sci-fi has
kernel density estimation and it's got
some quite a lot of optimized functions
so we use the the BFGS one which is a
second-order hessian approach that's
really nice really fast and some other
specific distributions too like the the
Weibull and the reilly and stuff and
then the custom ml algorithm is simply
conversion to and from NQ space and the
special case distributions things like
we wanted to fit sometimes to a uniform
right so that's that then finally a
third party circuit simulator in our
case you know we tie into these spy
simulators that other companies provide
so in general though it's pretty simple
right and that's part of the point
now I kind of touched on it when I was
back here I said when you want to go
from 3 Sigma 2 4 Sigma and you want to
simply extrapolate that's cool
but what if what if you actually can't
safely extrapolate what if things really
change once you get farther out in that
space and this can really happen right
let's say you have some sort of digital
circuit where it just simply
accidentally shuts off once you get say
a 3.5 Sigma once you get into a region
of your input space where just things
fall off a cliff right so no amount of
extrapolation will help you so what you
really need is you need actually good
data out here but to get good data out
here basically to go from 3 Sigma 4
Sigma you're going from a thousand
samples to about a million samples to go
to 5 or 6 Sigma to go to Six Sigma you
need about a billion or 10 billion
temples ok
so 10 billion temples the problem with
that is that you'd have to do 10 billion
simulations and that would take you
about 2 months on 100 cores right and
that's a problem of course because these
companies they design chips or they have
these cycles every three months or six
months you can't you can't consume 85 80
percent of your cycle by just waiting
for one design to verify right you've
got a ship that iPhone yesterday right
so it's a very very competitive industry
in time really matters so what you need
to do is you need to somehow get your
samples if this is the plus or minus 3
Sigma that a thousand samples will get
you need samples over here ok so a 5
Sigma Six Sigma and you need to do it in
10 minutes or an hour so there's quite a
few different approaches out there in
the literature to do this going back
even to the 50s so in the general class
of Monte Carlo algorithms there's some
sub classes called important sampling
and the idea there is to simply distort
the distribution to have samples Oh in
the tail it turns out that important
sampling isn't doesn't scale very well
it works for 10 variables or maybe 50
variables but a lot of our problems have
10,000 variables and it has actually
exponential increase in variance with
the number of dimensions so it's very
unhappy when you get to 10,000 variables
so what we needed we needed something
that work that had properties more like
plain Monte Carlo itself pseudo random
sampling drawing from the true
distribution which actually doesn't care
about the number of dimensions that's a
really cool magic trick about Monte
Carlo right if you look at the formula
from Monte Carlo its accuracy is only
dependent on the number of samples right
so that's a really cool property so we
said okay let's use that as a baseline
so let's draw 10 billion Monte Carlo
samples and let's simply figure out
which one which of those 10 billion
should we simulate and the way that we
figured that out is doing a very simple
pilot run to start with of about a
hundred or five hundred or thousand
simulations we build a model from that
and then we use that model to predict
which ones which samples might be out of
the tails okay so so if we do a thousand
simulations to build a model and then we
do another thousand then we affirm that
model of ten billion points we do
another thousand simulations that we
predicted which we think are the best
and even if the model isn't that great
we pick the ten best the ten that are
the most extreme values right here right
here and we show those so you can liken
this actually to sort of like a web
search Google search and in fact that
the shape of the problem is very similar
we've got ten thousand input variables
we've got about sort about ten billion
points in web they have typically they
start with say forty billion web pages
they chop it down to five billion using
heuristics and then they sorta they rank
it so we've got similar and then just
like you're viewing on a web page the
the first set of ten links from Google
we're showing the top ten results right
here we have ways actually to fill in
the rest to the rest of the PDF but just
focusing on the top ten is what matters
the most
so and the result is you can run this
for 20 minutes on ten cores or even
twenty minutes on a laptop these days
right so that's a lot better than two
months in a hundred or a thousand cores
and people are pretty happy about this
this has actually been adopted by the
majority of memory designers in the
world so if you have anything that uses
memory it's probably use this under the
hood we've been shipping this for about
four years now so the summary the stack
under that is it's using Python 2.7
numpy scifi it's using scikit-learn
pathways learning because it's using
this FFX algorithm this regression
algorithm I mentioned a few slides ago
it also has one percent C and it the
reason is when we're sorting those ten
billion points it's too slow to do it in
pure Python and we actually looked at a
whole bunch of the different
accelerators things like blaze and the
sort of stuff but in the end we went
straight for C so we're using C in two
things we generate the random numbers
using Mersenne twister which is actually
the default in python these days it
used to be but it is these days and for
each of those points after we generate
it we simulate the regressor the f-of-x
regressor in c and incidentally you
actually need something like Mersenne
twister it has a period of 10 to the 19
LCG these linear congruential generators
they only have a period of about 10 to
the 12 10 to the 13 and if you think
about it if we're looking at 10 billion
points that's 10 to the 10 right times
10 thousand variables that's 10 to the 4
so we're already at 10 to the 14 right
there so 10 to the 14 is big it's beyond
what a regular random number generator
can do so I was actually kind of
surprised by this right I've never ever
thought that something like LCG could
conk out but it actually literally does
in our case but we're sent Wistar we use
so that that's basically the stack that
we have for this this tool for a rare
event estimation here's another problem
that's kind of interesting
it's the idea also of searching through
structures so rather than searching
through a space of a Euclidean space or
maybe a discretized Euclidean space what
you're trying to do is actually you're
trying to come up with in this case
analog circuit topologies so a circuit
topology basically is a device like this
transistor here connected to this
transistor connected to this connected
to this in certain ways right and so you
can view it as a graph you can view it
in other ways too you can actually frame
this as a tree if you like as well and
actually that's how I did it here so I
actually came up with a language for
circuits a grammar for circuits and then
what I did was actually went through the
three or four major analog design
textbooks and I populated this language
with every circuit in all these analog
design textbooks so then in the end I
had a language for analog circuits and I
used genetic programming once again to
search through this language to come up
with optimal topologies so what the
results are here this is an example of
okay the an example of a trade-off
between gain bandwidth so gain and
bandwidth and power of a circuit and so
in this case along here every single one
of these points is actually a size
topology in this case it's this topology
but each one of these points along here
is just a this topology with different
sizings but once it gets to a certain
point in this case about 1.8 gigahertz
of game bandwidth
it needs to switch to a different
topology and you can see it goes from
here to here and it's a more complex
topology it's got this second path and
that path actually doubles the power
consumption so you can see here this is
power consumption on the y-axis right so
in order to get a gain-bandwidth beyond
a certain point you need to switch to a
different topology that is super useful
for analog designers to know okay it's
really really cool knowledge this is
also cool because it is directly tied to
the silicon information itself so you
you run this once at you know the most
modern process known these days that's
fourteen or sixteen nanometers and then
you have this information and you're
good to go all right
the stack is similar to the other ones
that's grammar constrained genetic
programming it's also got a derivative
free optimizer that we rolled and the
high resolution interpolator just for
some of this this is also open source at
Trent St slash mojito that's my second
favorite drink it's my wife's favorite
actually
but it's my second favorite okay I guess
I'm running out of time but there's I
talked it with this problem of machine
lis of corner analysis and the idea
there is you've got these three thousand
corners but you only have time to do 100
simulations how do you verify across
those three thousand corners you can
cast this as a global optimization
problem and then you can solve it that
way and you have to make sure that the
global optimizer solves in a very very
reliable fashion and so we used what we
call model building optimization other
people call it sequential model building
optimization or Bayesian optimization
and that's how we kind of approach it
here's a screenshot from the tool and
then we solve it in a reliable fashion
and in this case to solve this problem
of three thousand corners we can solve
it in two hundred seventy-five
simulations okay
so designers really like that some of
our customers use this for every single
circuit that they ship so every single
custom circuit the likes of Nvidia
Qualcomm these sorts of companies every
single shirt circuit that comes out of
them runs through this tool okay so I've
talked to I don't have time to go into
detail under the hood the model building
it's using Gaussian process models which
also very happily is proto scikit-learn
we used to have to roll our own but we
were very happy that scikit-learn has
that it turns out that it doesn't quite
scale beyond about a thousand samples so
we had to have a divide-and-conquer
approach to take it farther
and so the divide-and-conquer approach
is basically a cart model that wraps
Gaussian process model
okay so cart at the top level Gaussian
process models at the lowest level so a
Gaussian process models when you're for
every seven hundred samples never more
than 700 training samples and that
actually gives it an overall order the N
log n learning because now you have o to
the 1 learning on the Gaussian process
models Gaussian process models
traditionally are order the N cubed in
the number of training points so that
was actually a huge benefit for us we
went from o to the N cubed 2 o to the n
log n right and then made a big
difference for our customers because
they were starting to attack these
larger problems where they needed to
have 10,000 training points or even more
and it turns out that this thing
benchmarks really well you know places
like 10x faster 100x faster places were
playing galaxies across and bought
models completely failed we could solve
and even have lower error so we were
happy about that there here's another
very quick thing if you're trying to do
just simple random sampling maybe
Mersenne twister or something else if
you're doing random sampling and a 2d
uniformly distributed space some of
those samples could clump together or
maybe they have big gaps right so if
you're trying to estimate say the the
mean or the standard deviation that
actually increases the variance of those
estimates it turns out that this
technology like lattice rules and other
load it's compressing sampling
approaches they give you a perfectly
spread a set of samples okay what that
does then is it means you can have a
lower variance estimate of mean and
standard deviation and so on and
latticed rules is actually among the
best because it actually can scale up to
a thousand ten thousand plus variables
other approaches things like latin
hypercube or digital nets or halton
these sorts of things they actually have
issues like scalability or only not
considering variable interactions and
this gives speed ups you know here's one
set of benchmarks here's a good example
of the variance reduction so this is
plain pseudo random sampling versus the
very the lower variance so this is the
number of samples in log scale this is
the average error and estimating mean
and you can see for example if you want
to estimate mean within two percent
accuracy it's actually it means 10x
fewer samples and actually as you want
to get lower lower accuracy you get even
bigger speed ups so if you want to get
within say 0.1 percent accuracy you've
got a
speed up so this is pretty cool right so
if you're using random sample and you
want to get a 2x or a hundred X for free
use lattice rules and you know lots of
we have a lot of benchmarks on this and
also you know we use in this case we
have another tool that's for it's like
optimization but it's a really beautiful
interface so you can explore and slice
and dice the space it's sort of like the
technology soccer before except we've
got qt4 and choco see these are
chocolates inside my company inside
Toledo we actually have in the overall
we have six different product and each
of these products has a giant list of
different machine learning tools that we
use I know that it's pretty small font
there but to give it a feel on the top
left we've got regression and
interpolation with confidence intervals
we've got model-based optimization in
the middle we've got loaded scripting
sampling 1d density estimation and so on
and so forth so a lot of machine
learning and a whole bunch of different
ways as far as our customers are
concerned as far as our users are
concerned they've got this really
beautiful interface that just works they
don't have to think about the machine
learning they don't have to think about
the code they're just using a tool
something like this okay so in
conclusion you've seen a talk now on how
Python and machine learning are
literally helping to drive Moore's Law
it's the silicon Midas touch applied to
itself and if you've got a cell phone in
your pocket that Python that machine
their name almost certainly had a hand
in designing that phone and the servers
in the cloud all of these chips and
that's all thank you very much
that was very impressive does anyone
have any questions you said you were
working with multi objective
optimization how many objectives and
what sort of properties they have yeah
so we mostly work with multi objective
in two places in let's see here in this
problem in the white box modeling in
this case it was two objectives so
minimizing prediction error on unseen
data and minimizing complexity in other
cases in this particular problem right
here here we have two objectives but in
this case there's actually up to eight
objectives and that problem changes
dramatically because you're the high the
the volume of the surface or the the
hyper area of the surface that you're
trying to cover grows exponentially and
if you use the wrong multi objective
search it's going to spend all this time
searching the corners so something like
NS GA 2 will completely fail and what we
did here was we used a variant of what's
it called well it's another multi
objective variant like a multi objective
evolutionary algorithm that spent more
time on the knee so basically more
towards the center of the trade-off it
also spent some time along the edges but
we focused it more towards the center
and so that made it possible okay okay
and I guess one other thing related to
that - we also have constraints on this
so I said constrain multi objective
search so you might say you know what
you never any power consumption beyond
50 milliwatts and if you can drop that
out immediately it means that it's not
spending any effort really searching
that space once you've met your
constraints okay thank you
okay so it looks like there is no other
question if you have any questions feel
free to ask them offline and we break
for lunch now thank you as well
you